E aí
[Música]
o Olá hoje eu falarei sobre o lixo
espacial
é um dia eu estava na internet
procurando sobre os planos de
colonização de Marte quando eu vi um tem
um novo que não conhecia lixo espacial
esse termo me deixou um tanto quanto
curioso então eu decidi procurar mais
sobre ele e eu descobri que ele se
passou é um grande programa que pode não
só impedir todos os nossos planos
relativos à exploração espacial Mas pode
também destruir muito de nosso satélite
ao que causaria grandes problemas para
todos nós
o OK mas então porque ele disse passar
um problema tão grande
primeiramente a maioria das nossas
tecnologias atuais dependendo do sub
satélites coisas como o GPS sistema de
comunicação Global a previsão do tempo
atividades militares e muitos outros
recursos são exemplos de coisas que
precisam dos satélites e sentimos muita
falta se desaparecesse se esse recurso
me senti um dia para o outro as nossas
vidas mudaram por completo
o outro grande problema é crise parcial
poderia tornar a viagem espacial
impossível impossibilitando coisas que
eu e muitos outros acham interessantes
emocionantes importantes coisas como
descobrir mais sobre nosso universo
explorar e colonizar outros planetas se
tornaram mais péssimo super etária
contra entre diversas outras atividades
o ok então eu já te disse o que ele
espacial pode causar e porque ele é um
pro não é tão grande mas eu não te disse
exatamente o que ele é não é mesmo bem
lixo espacial é qualquer objeto que
permanece no espaço o que foi feito pelo
homem embora não se vá mais além um
propósito alguns exemplos de se torne
espacial são satélites antigos que não
funcionam mais e peças de foguetes que
foram simplesmente deixadas no espaço
e o problema desse lista parcial é que o
único pedaço de tecido minúsculo tem
poder suficiente para incapacitar o às
vezes até mesmo destruir um satélite
inteiro isso é um satélite for destruído
uma reação em cadeia exponenciar pode
ocorrer que pode não só destruir todos
os outros a técnicos Mas pode também
acabar com todos os nossos planos
relativos ao espaço deixa eu explicar
imagina aqui órbita da terra está cheia
de lixo lixo que vai ficar lá por muitos
muitos anos e esse visto a se movimentar
mais gosto de incrível poder e nem
imaginavam bem esse bicho aí funcionar
como uma espécie de escudo ao redor do
planeta que nos impedirá de viajar para
o espaço e fazer qualquer coisa lá
nem mesmo Cristo facial seja uma coisa
tão assustadora tô esperança não está
perdida na verdade existem muitas
maneiras interessantes de resolver esse
problema
em quase todas elas envolvem o envio de
um satélite para o espaço para coletar o
destino lixo a Universidade de surrey na
Inglaterra considera a enviar um
satélite com uma rede o arpão que
capturará o lixo em seguida o levará de
volta para a terra esses métodos que
envolvem contato são Com certeza
promissores porém eu considero métodos
que não envolvem contato mais adequados
algumas maneiras de limpar o espaço
assim só em ver ela é crime a gigante
para o espaço ela é tem umas que jogaria
um olho espacial para o esporte da
atmosfera terrestre gerando uma
quantidade gigantesca de atrito entre o
lixo EA atmosfera fazendo com Felipe ou
seja incinerado
É um cientista australiano renovado
chamado craques wi-fi também considera a
usar laser laser gigantescos para
ensinar pedaço de lixa pequenos e
queimar partes de satélites maiores os
enviando para mais perto da atmosfera
terrestre
mesmo que o lixo espacial seja um
conceito tão assustador e cientistas já
estão pensando em algumas maneiras de
como resolvê-lo no momento atual não
estamos fazendo nada porque é uma
explicação para isso não há nenhum
incentivo econômico nem leis que regulem
a poluição espaço eu pessoalmente
acredito que regularmente devem ser
feitos para que países e empresas sejam
responsáveis por exorbitar o lixo que
eles fizeram regulamentos como obrigar
que tecnologias de deslocamentos sejam
implementados em todos os satélites que
serão enviados por espaço no futuro no
entanto o espaço não é regra não é
o Jin e criar regras para lá é muito
difícil muitos países teriam que essas
regras juntos e empresas terão que
respeitar lá infelizmente Estamos muito
mais interessados e mandar coisas para o
espaço do quem levava de volta para
Terra
e o lixo espacial tem muitas semelhanças
com tem medo corrija os dois são
extremamente complexos a nossa própria
existência pode dependendo do combate
desse problemas porém água ainda mais
importante é que a convite poderia ter
sido combatida muito mais facilmente em
seus estágios iniciais assim como eles
espacial Infelizmente hoje espacial
ainda não se tornou um problema tão
grande né Ainda podemos combater Mas
precisamos agir antes que seja tarde
demais obrigado
E aí
[Música]